- On this episode, I go back outside,
because you asked for it.
(electronic rhythm)
You ask questions,
and I answer them
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 144
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
It is a Friday, beautiful
Friday here in New York City.
The pope is comin' through,
causin' a lot of ruckus,
traffic-wise.
But, I'm in a good mood, because
my official Jets-Eagles
prediction is coming up,
India's back, that always feels good,
and yesterday's show got
a lot of great comments,
a lot of good feedback from the show,
we went deep, quite emotional,
a little heartache on episode 143,
so India, lets get into-
- the-
- The show.
- Almost.
- Let's do it.
- I feel satisfied that I got you
on the early come-up.
So...
- From Anthony.
- Anthony.
- We're actually, no,
we're gonna start with Ari.
- Oh, what happened to Anthony?
- Anthony's is like, fun,
so we'll do it later.
- Well, why can't we do,
why can't we start 144
with some fun?
- I like to set the pacing.
- Fine, set your pacing, go ahead, Ari.
- Alright, well, now I feel like you're
gonna be judgmental
of Ari's question.
- Ari's question's in deep shit.
- [Voiceover] Ari asks,
"How can I deal with
"the perfectionism and
feeling like someone else
"can do it better preventing
me from getting stuff done?"
- I don't even understand, do it again.
How can I what?
- How can, like, what do you do-
- No no, read it again, I
was like, you went too fast.
- Okay, "how can I deal
with perfectionism-
- "How can I deal with perfectionism?"
- Ari.
- Ari, go ahead.
I understand, not me, thanks India.
- "and feeling like someone
else can do it better
"preventing me from getting stuff done?"
- Got it, so, he not only
wants everything to be perfect,
he always has a sense that
somebody else can do it better.
- Yeah, probably.
- Ari, you need to get over yourself.
Like, you know, the reality is,
I think speed trumps so
much that I'm blown away
by people that get caught up in this
and really, it just leads to
you being disproportionately
not successful because you're too slow,
you're overthinking
things, and I feel like,
a lot of times, people screw things up
by trying to do too much
instead of just letting it be.
That's why I like doing one take.
It just, it's gonna be what it's gonna be.
You get another at bat
another day in the future.
I don't know if I can motivate
you through this answer
to say, you know, get
over yourself, move on,
change, I think it is a DNA thing,
I think it's tough for people
to break out of that habit.
I'm absolutely massively thankful
that I'm completely the other way.
I probably go too fast,
I probably only execute
at 94%, 96%, 87%, 91%,
86%, consistently, but I'd
rather do five things than
after I just told you that story,
you doing one thing at 97%,
not even 100 to begin with.
There is no 100% Ari, it's
just not the way it really is.
The market decides if it was good
or if somebody can do it better.
There's a level of anxiety
and a little bit of, like,
getting over it that you're
just gonna have to do.
The fact that you're asking the question
means you're self-aware
that it's an issue.
I think the best way to
get things done in life
is to just do them.
You're gonna learn how to
swim by jumping in the pool
and learning how to swim.
I think the number one thing you can do
is make the next four to six projects
and make it painful for yourself,
just let it go, see what happens,
when you start tasting
like, oh wait a minute,
that wasn't so bad, away you go.
- Nice. From Eli.
- People overthink, India.
It's overthinking, guys.
It just, it's overthinking.
- You ready?
- Excuse me.
Excuse me, do you think
people overthink too much?
Yeah.
It's overthinking.
(laughs)
She had no interest on being on the show.
- [Voiceover] Eli asks, "My
company brokers commodities
"from the producers/hedgers
to the consumers.
"All of my current and potential customers
"are large commercial and
industrial property owners.
"What would be the best
way for me to leverage
"social media marketing to try and increase
"my customer base in this
strictly B2B atmosphere?
PS, Chris Ivory is a boss."
- Chris Ivory is a boss, I think
he might not play this week
for the Jets, I'm concerned.
I would go out and create white papers
on SlideShare and then run
LinkedIn and Facebook ads
against those white papers.
What I mean by that is, when
you into a B2B environment,
I believe that long form
becomes much more valuable
than short form.
I think that you reverse the
headlines that people think
that it needs to be
all short form content,
I think you know your audience,
you know who your buyers
are in a B2B environment,
you know what they value,
and you need to deliver on that.
And so, that's exactly what I would do,
I would go out, and I would
create long form content
that's valuable to them,
and not a sales pitch
that's valuable to you.
But content that those
decision makers need,
not just for what you do for a living,
but holistically, let
me give you an example.
Even though I'm trying
to get CMOs as clients,
I might be able to put out content
that teaches them about Cloud computing,
or IT infrastructure, or I
would make a white paper of
how the CMO needs to
interact with the CIO.
These are valuable pieces of content
that I brought to them
that have nothing to do
with hire me as an agency to do your work,
but I brought you value
in a nine page deck
that you saw on LinkedIn
because I targeted you properly,
so that's what I would think about,
create long form content in video,
in audio, but in definitely deck form,
B2B people love decks.
And get that in front of
them through targeting
on LinkedIn and Facebook, put
your branding on the bottom,
make the last click go to your world,
provide them value, do what I always say,
become a media company, not just around
what you do for a
living, but what actually
brings them value, and
so what I would do is
I would call, and let's get real tactical,
I would literally call the
25 customers, 50 customers
you have right now,
call them and say "Hey."
Real quick, if you've got two minutes,
maybe email them, 'cause people
don't like people calling.
Email them, say, "Do you
have two minutes for me,
"I'm looking to provide you more value,"
you call them and say, "Hey, what are
"your other business problems or frictions
"besides what we do
together in the world."
If eight out of 25 of
them say the same thing,
that would become my first content pillar
to put out to the world.
Bringing value to people is
an amazing way to guilt them
into doing business with
you, even if you bring
value to them in a genre
that has nothing to do
with your own, but is still
within the collective,
cohesive unit of what
they do for a living.
Stefan, fire emoji out of my mouth,
at the end there.
- This one caused a lot of
controversy this morning
amongst the teams, we can't really,
we don't know what he's talking about,
but we think it's funny, so.
- So one more time, the entire team-
- We were trying to unpack
it altogether at our desks,
there was so much going
on in the question,
we're not really sure, we want
to see if you understand it,
because none of us do.
- Of course I understand it,
this is the #AskGaryVee Show,
India.
Go ahead.
- I co-own two karate schools-
- I understand that he
co-owns two karate schools.
- Just wait.
- Okay, go 'head.
- In influential Westchester, New York.
I think he means they're influential-
- Yeah, I mean, in just Westchester,
he just means Westchester, he was just
hyperbolizing Westchester.
Lizzie's from Westchester, big ups.
- I handle biz, not instructor.
- What?
I handle the business side,
I'm not a karate instructor.
- How do I-
(both laugh)
- Stick with me, India.
- How do I, how do I tell
members I'm now a realtor?
(all laugh)
- Amazing!
Okay.
Wait, what's the name?
- Excel Martial Arts.
- Excel Martial Arts, I
assume what you're saying is
you do business development
for two karate studios
in Westchester, all your social
media has been around that,
and now you're making a
segue into becoming realtor
and selling homes in the market.
You're speaking to the right guy.
I told the world for nine years,
or, for 15 years, that
I was a wine merchant,
and that I was a wine connoisseur,
and that I was a wine expert, and then,
just by putting out business content,
'cause I had the chops, I told them
that I was a business personality.
If you know what you're talking about
as a realtor-
if- if you, nice photobomb,
I appreciate that.
- I gotchu, man.
- If you actually know
what you're talking about
from a realtor standpoint, and
you have smart points of view
on the neighborhood dynamics, the upsides
in which neighborhoods in Westchester
are "blowing up," things of that nature,
then I think you have a huge opportunity,
and so, the answer is quite simple.
The- the final line is,
"How do I know tell them"
- "How do I tell members
I'm now a realtor?"
- Members?
- Yeah.
- So I wonder if he's
trying to sell people
that are coming in for karate,
to like, buy a home.
I, you know, the answer
is, I wouldn't sell them
in the studio, I would just
start putting out content
across all social platforms
with your points of view,
not just selling a home and saying,
"Hey, come to my open house this weekend,"
no, say things like, you know,
I see a huge opportunity in White Plains,
and south of the train station,
I see that as a, or in Harrison,
they have a great school system,
like, those kinda things, provide value,
provide value, provide value, guys,
we're a 144 shows in,
if you don't understand
that you need to provide value
versus selling to people,
then you, you should stop watching
the god damn show.
- We did it, we got it.
- We got through that one.
Alright.
- [Voiceover] Kevin asks,
"How can illustrators
"market themselves and
distinguish themselves
"from the competition?"
- Ooh, that's nice.
I look like Jake Benrubi,
a little bit, in that.
You see it?
I'm changing my angle here
on ya, a little bit, DRock.
I think illustrators should
really focus on Snapchat.
I think Snapchat's a
really interesting place
where they can pop.
I think that Facebook,
targeting publishers.
So, creating illustrations,
and then running
$50 worth of ads against
employees of publishers,
I think is a very smart place to go,
because I think people will notice.
Shh.
(girls laugh)
And then I think what
really, really would work
is responding to people on
Twitter around subject matters
and then creating illustrations
around those subject matters,
I think has enormous upside.
If you can show your speed to
illustrate around conversation
in that environment, I think
there's a real opportunity.
So those are three tactics.
I mean, look, an illustrator's
gonna break out from the heap
by being a great illustrator.
How often you could put
yourself in a position
to have people see your
work is going to become
the way that you're successful.
I also think, illustrate hacking.
Meaning, making illustrations of Gary Vee,
I don't like using the third person,
making illustrations of me
is gonna make me see it.
I would go after other microinfluencers,
not A-list celebrities, sort
of immune to that stuff,
other microinfluencers, illustrate them,
reply to them, I think that's
an enormous opportunity.
Put it on Instagram and then tag them,
'cause they'll see it,
those kinda things are cool.
- [Voiceover] Anthony asks, "Hey Gary Vee,
"who is your all time favorite Jet
"and all- time least favorite Jet
"and why?"
- My all time favorite Jet and
my all time least favorite Jet.
My all time least favorite
Jet is probably Kyle Wilson.
He just ended being a Jet.
Kyle, if you're watching
this, I apologize,
it's just the truth.
He was a first-round pick.
He was terrible every second of the way.
Just, broke my heart.
Just did not like the way he played.
Didn't feel that he had
ball skills for a corner.
Even when, like, our starting
corners would get hurt
he would have to not
play, he was a terrible,
I just really disliked him.
My favorite all time Jet is Al Toon.
I was a young kid, he
was our best receiver,
number 88, I loved him with all my heart,
I love you, Al Toon, if you're watching.
And that's it.
Those are the real
answers to that question.
- That's everything.
- That's it?
That's the show? Alright.
Official prediction time.
This one's gonna hurt.
I have a feeling that Decker
and Ivory are not playing.
I'm, I think the Eagles are
playing for their lives.
I think that the Jets, I don't think,
the Jets have never beaten the Eagles
in NFL history, in a regular season game.
And I'm very, very concerned of this,
I'm still very affected
by the 1994, '93, '94 game
where the Jets were up 21-7
against the Eagles at home,
and then Eric Allen had
a 99-yard interception
return for a touchdown as
the Jets were about to go up
28 to 7 in Johnny Mitchell's
coming out party game.
Eagles went on to win.
There's just something
bad about this game,
I'm taking a ton of VaynerMedia
Eagle fan employees,
Mark Evans, and Brandon
Resnic, and Taggart,
and Lindsey, Price, I think I'm bringing
too many employees to the game,
that feels wrong, and I think the Jets,
the Jets stumble here.
I think that, I think they
stumble here, unfortunately,
I'm gonna go Eagles 20, Jets 16.
Hurts my feelings to go that route,
but that's, that's my official prediction.
I'm not gonna predict
them to win every week,
I will not be surprised if they win,
I feel nice that they could win,
but my official prediction is
the Jets stumble this week,
20 to 16, but just to
give you some insight,
I think they rally next week in London,
anything can change,
but that's how I feel.
Sorry for myself.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(thumping bass)